Power is one of those terms that we all think we understand. It's being in a position to call the shots, to set the agenda, to lead others and maybe to boss them around or even punish them, right? Our culture's understanding of power has been heavily shaped by one person, Niccolo Machiavelli, the Renaissance era politician and diplomat, who infamously wrote that power is essentially about force, fraud, ruthlessness, and strategic violence. But what if he was wrong? So what is power? Why do people people seek it? What types of people seek it? And if you want power, what's the best way to get it? Is it human nature to abuse power? And why do some people lust for it? What is the impact of powerlessness? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American
权力是我们自认为都理解的术语之一。它意味着处于发号施令、制定议程、领导他人，甚至可能对他人颐指气使，或者惩罚他们的位置，对吧？我们文化对权力的理解在很大程度上受到尼科洛·马基雅维利的影响，这位文艺复兴时期的政治家和外交官曾臭名昭著地写道，权力本质上关乎武力、欺诈、冷酷和战略暴力。但如果他错了呢？那么什么是权力？为什么人们追求权力？什么样的人会追求权力？如果你想要权力，获得它的最好方法是什么？滥用权力是人性使然吗？为什么有些人渴望权力？无权无势会带来什么影响？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是达彻·凯尔特纳博士，他是至善科学中心创始主任，也是加州大学伯克利分校的心理学教授。他著有畅销书《权力悖论：我们如何获得和失去影响力》，同时也是播客《幸福科学》的主持人，该播客也是他共同教授的一门热门课程的名称。权力是他研究的众多领域之一，其他领域还包括爱、同情心、美、社会阶层、不平等和敬畏。感谢您今天加入我们，凯尔特纳博士。很高兴能与您在一起，金。在《心理学谈话》节目中，我们通常从定义术语开始。
Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Dacher Keltner, founding director of the Greater Good Science Center and Psychology Professor at the University of California, Berkeley. He is author of the best-selling book, The Power Paradox, How We Gain and Lose Influence, as well as host of the podcast, The Science of Happiness, which is also the name of a popular course that he co-instructs. Power is one of the many areas he studies along with love, compassion, beauty, social class, inequality, and awe. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Keltner. It's great to be with you, Kim. Here at speaking of psychology, we often start by defining terms.
我在介绍中问了这个问题，什么是权力？你如何定义它？你的定义与马基雅维利的定义不同吗？是的，你知道，这被证明是权力科学中最难做的事情之一。伟大的哲学家伯特兰·罗素曾写道，权力是社会生活的基本媒介。我和同事们研究权力25年了，我倾向于同意这一点。它无处不在，这使得它很难定义。
And I ask this question in the introduction, what is power? How do you define it? And is your definition different from Machiavelli's? Yeah, you know, this turns out to be one of the hardest things to do in the science of power. You know, Bertrand Russell, the great philosopher, wrote that power is the basic medium of social life. And as I've studied power with my colleagues for 25 years, I tend to agree. It's just everywhere. and that makes it hard to define.
我们确实达成了一致，虽然对它有各种定义，但我们确实与一位名叫斯蒂芬·卢克斯的人保持一致，他对权力有很好的论述。他是一位社会学家，认为权力是你改变他人状态或影响他人的能力，对吧？所以权力不同于地位，卡梅伦·安德森研究过地位，即你从同龄人、同事和周围人那里获得的尊重。权力不同于财富和阶级。事实上，在我们的工作中，这两个概念的相关性仅为0.15到0.2。权力不同于支配，支配是胁迫他人、操纵他人的策略。
And we really align, and there are various definitions of it, but we really align with somebody named Stephen Luke's who has a wonderful treatment of power. He's a sociologist that power is your capacity to alter the states of other people or to influence others, right? So power is different from status, which Cameron Anderson has studied, which is the respect you get from your peers and your colleagues and the people around you. Power is different than wealth and class. And in fact, in our work, those two constructs only correlate about 0.15.2. Power is different from dominance, which is strategies to coerce people to manipulate.
权力是你影响和改变周围人心智状态的能力。那么为什么有些人追求权力？积极想要权力的人有哪些心理社会特征？嗯，你知道，这是一个古老的问题。像大卫·温特这样的人确实对此很感兴趣。你知道，我们在多大程度上想要权力存在个体差异。有些人想要聚光灯。他们想要领导。
Power is your capacity to influence and alter the states of mind of people around you. So why do some people seek power? What are the psychosocial hallmarks of people who actively want power? Well, you know, this is an old question. People like David Winter really were interested in it. It's, you know, there are individual differences in how much we want power. Some people want the spotlight. They want to lead.
他们有某些特征。他们喜欢权力。他们享受权力。他们稍微外向一点。我认为我们为什么想要权力是这项研究中真正微妙的教训之一，那就是权力会带来很多好处。人们感觉更好，他们更快乐，他们有更多的自由，他们与他人的联系更多，他们享受更多的资源。所以想要权力有很多正当理由，我们不应该
They have certain characteristics. They like power. They enjoy it. They're a little bit more extroverted. Why we want that is I think one of the really subtle lessons of this research, which is that there are a lot of good things that come with power. people feel better, they are happier, they have more freedom, they have more connections with others, they enjoy more resources. So there are a lot of good reasons for wanting power, and we shouldn't
谴责人们有这种抱负。为什么其他人逃避权力？这仅仅是对责任的恐惧吗？嗯，是的，我认为这是部分原因。我认为部分原因是权力的社会义务，人们会关注你。如果你愿意的话，你处于聚光灯下。你对其他人的福利负有责任。也许这就是为什么更外向的人会被权力职位所吸引并想要它。而那些稍微安静、害羞的人等等
condemn people for that aspiration. Why do other people run away from power? Is it just a fear of responsibility? Well, yeah, I think that's part of it. I think part of it is the social obligations of power that you're, people are going to be attending to you. You're in the spotlight, if you will. You have responsibilities over other people's welfare. And perhaps that's why more extroverted people gravitate to positions of power and want it. And people who are a little bit quieter, shyer and the like
可能最初会回避它。但这一论点目前在不同领域受到挑战。所以我认为人们回避它的部分原因是当你拥有权力后被迫承受的关注。但拥有权力不是几乎不可能的吗？我的意思是，你知道，无论你是有了孩子必须抚养他们，还是你有一份工作，你知道，你在日常生活中拥有一定程度的权力。我的意思是，真的很难完全没有权力，不是吗？
are maybe initially shy away from it. But that thesis is being challenged in different sectors right now. So I think part of the reason that people shy away from is the attention that is forced upon you once you have power. But isn't it almost impossible to have no power? I mean, you know, whether it's you've got kids and you have to raise them or you've got a job and, you know, you've got a certain level of power within what you do every day in your life. I mean, it's really hard to have no power, isn't it?
是的，你知道，金，我的意思是，你的问题确实让我思考了很长时间的权力，那就是我是在60年代末嬉皮士的乌托邦世界中长大的，比如，让我们摆脱权力。我曾经相信这一点。然后生活让我面对真相，那就是我们总是拥有某种程度的权力，对吧？在每一段关系中，如果你抚养孩子，就会有权力动态。生物学家现在发现，从女性怀孕到生命结束，对吧？所以权力只是游戏的一部分。我们总是拥有某种程度的权力。这就是为什么我们认为必须认真对待这门科学，那就是如果它是生活的基本媒介，无论我们是在抚养
Yeah, you know, Kim, I mean, that, your question is what really got me to think about power for a long time, which is that I grew up. raised by hippies in this late 60s utopian world of like, let's get rid of power. And I kind of believe that. And then life confronted me with truth, which is we always have some degree of power, right? In every relationship, if you raise kids, there are going to be power dynamics. Biologists are now discovering from when the woman is pregnant until the end of life, right? So power is just part of the game. We always have some degree of it. And that's why we think we have to take this science seriously, which is that if it is this basic medium of life, whether we're raising
孩子，还是在浪漫关系中，或者与朋友在一起，或者在群体中，我们必须用我们拥有的权力做好工作。但它处于从极少到极大的维度上。说到巨大的权力，我的意思是，有一句古老的格言说绝对的权力导致腐败，或者说权力导致腐败，绝对的权力导致绝对的腐败。在你的经验和你所做的工作中，这是真的吗？是的，你知道，我认为科学文献发现的情况稍微微妙一些。我认为这就是为什么我们与卡梅伦·安德森和黛布·格伦菲尔德一起将我们的理论称为
kids or in romantic relations or with friends or, you know, in groups, we got to do a good job with the power that we have. But it is on a dimension from very little to a great deal. So talking about a great deal of power, I mean, there is the old adage that absolute power corrupts or that power corrupts and absolute power corrupts absolutely. Is that true in New experience and in the work that you've done? Yeah, you know, I think there's a, it's a little bit more subtle the scientific literature finds. And I think that's why we called our theory with Cameron Anderson and Deb Grunfeld about
权力去抑制。我认为这是更广泛的真理，那就是我们有这些倾向。它们根据你个人的身份而变化。权力倾向于让你自由地表达你的倾向，而不受社会约束或行为后果的影响。现在，总的来说，人们往往更自私、更关注自我，并希望最大化自己的收益。所以当我们拥有权力时，我们确实会变得稍微自恋一些，
power disinhibiting you. And I think that that's the broader truth, which is that we have these tendencies. They vary according to who you are as a person. And power tends to free you up to express your tendencies, independent of social constraint. or the consequences of your behavior. Now, in general, people tend to be a little bit more self-serving and self-focused and wanting to maximize their own gains. And so when we have power, we do become a little bit more narcissistic,
稍微不太关注他人，行为稍微冲动一些。但是，你知道，塞雷娜·陈做过非常出色的工作。我在伯克利的同事展示了，其他人也展示了，你知道，如果我是达赖喇嘛，我很善良且富有同情心，你知道，突然我有了权力。它实际上去抑制了我更强的亲社会倾向，我的同理心、善良和分享。这有一个非常重要的教训，那就是我们必须小心我们把权力交给谁。你知道，如果我们坚持认为权力应该交给马基雅维利主义者，也就是你之前提到的那些人，而我们只是通过刻板印象
a little bit more less attentive to other people, a little bit more impulsive in our behaviors. But, you know, Serena Chen has done really nice work. My colleague at Berkeley is showing and others have that, you know, if I'm, the Dalai Lama and I'm kind and compassionate, you know, and suddenly I have power. It actually disinhibits my greater pro-social tendencies, my empathy and my kindness and sharing. And that has a really important lesson, which is we got to be careful about who we give power to. You know, and if we we hew to this idea that power should go to the Machiavellians, who you raised earlier, and we just, through stereotypes,
和误解把权力交给威权类型的人，或者我们认为符合这种模式的人，我们可能会通过允许他们表达更马基雅维利的倾向而使许多问题长期存在。好吧，我们的朋友马基雅维利也断言，被人畏惧胜过被人爱戴，对吧？我们对那些被人畏惧且本质上是在滥用权力的人的长期影响了解多少？你知道，我非常感激，金，你提到了我自己的马基雅维利，你正确地构建了它，人们没有意识到，你知道，马基雅维利在16世纪初写了《君主论》。
and misconceptions give power to the authoritarian type or the person we think fits the model, we may be perpetuating a lot of problems by allowing them to express their more Machiavellian tendencies. Well, our friend Machiavelli also asserted that it's better to be feared than loved, right? What do we know about the long-term effects of people who are feared and are essentially, I mean, they're misusing their power? You know, I'm so grateful, Kim, you bring up my own. Machiavelli and you rightly frame it and people don't realize, you know, Machiavelli wrote the prince in the early 16th century.
那是文艺复兴时代。文化大爆发。人们实际上不知道他关于权力的言论是否真诚，因为他是一位剧作家和讽刺作家等等。同样重要的是要记住，他写于人类历史上最暴力的时期之一，对吧？你知道，酷刑、暴力、雇佣兵和性暴力随处可见。所以他的论点是权力关乎操纵、欺骗、在你没有宗教承诺时假装有。这让我想起了我们的前总统，你知道，以及伤害。他确实建议你伤害你的盟友，对吧？你削弱周围的其他人。
It was the age of the Renaissance. There was all this explosion of culture. People actually don't know whether he was sincere in what he said about power because he was a playwright and a satirist and the like. And it's also important to remember that he wrote in one of the most violent times in human history, right? you know, torture and violence and mercenaries and sexual violence were just everywhere. And so his thesis was powers about manipulation, deception, feigning a religious commitment when you don't have it. And it reminds me of our former president, you know, and harm. He really recommended you hurt your allies, right? You weaken others around you.
坦率地说，在今天的大多数地方，实证文献表明这种权力模式对你没有好处，对吧？如果你在工作中应用它，它对你没有好处。如果你作为一名心理学家或教师应用它，你不会在等级制度中晋升。如果你实践那种权力哲学，你会导致与他人的孤立。你会不那么快乐。它在某些领域确实有效。如果我在贩毒集团，我可能会非常仔细地研究《君主论》，你知道。但它，嗯，我是一个，嗯，我是一个，它正在逐渐退出作为主流权力模式，当然也有非常有趣的政治例外。我们最近经历了威权主义的抬头。
And frankly, in most places to... today the empirical literature shows that model of power doesn't serve you well, right? It won't serve you well at work. You don't rise in the ranks if you apply it in, you know, as a psychologist or teacher. It leads to isolation with other people. You're less happy if you practice that philosophy of power. It does work in certain sectors. If I was in a drug cartel, I'd probably study the prints very carefully, you know. But it's, um, I'm a, um, I'm a, It is gradually moving its way out of as being the prevailing model of power with really interesting political exceptions. We had this bump in authoritarianism recently.
这可能正在稍微减弱。所以我们如何对待权力，马基雅维利式的方法还是更协作的方法，这总是一个斗争。这就是它如此动态的原因。很难不把你对我们过去经历的事情的思考应用到最近的政府中。让我这样说吧。我的意思是，那是一个在权力概念上非常贪婪的人，然而即使在他拥有某种终极权力时，似乎也非常不快乐。
That may be on the wane a little. And so it's always a struggle how we approach power, Machiavillian approaches or more collaborative approaches. And that's what makes it so dynamic. It's hard not to apply your thinking to. what we've been going through in the last, in the last administration. Let me put it that way. I mean, that was a person who was very lustful when it came to the concept of a power and yet seemed very unhappy, even when he had kind of the ultimate power.
现在他仍然试图把它夺回来。是的。我的意思是，你知道，我把这本书命名为《权力悖论》，因为它是一种有趣的兴衰动态。你知道，我只是，这不仅仅是男人和政治，这只是生活。我刚才正在和一位来自边缘化社区的领先女权主义者交谈，她说，这也发生在我身上。我崛起了。我有这个信息。我吸引了很多人，然后我发现自己失去了联系。我认为你可以看看
And now he's still out there trying to grab it back. Yeah. I mean, you know, I titled this book, The Power Paradox, because it is this interesting rise and fall dynamic. You know, I was just, and this isn't just. men and politics, this is just life. I was just talking to a leading, you know, feminists from marginalized community who said, this happened to me too. I rose. I had this message. I appealed to a lot of people and then I found myself losing touch. And I think you could look at
上一届总统任期，作为一个教科书式的例子，某人通过汉娜·阿伦特所说的，通过接触网络并激励他们来获得权力，让我们感到惊讶。他与人们交谈，然后他行事的方式，以及新冠疫情的后果，以及我们作为一种文化的失败，说明了当我们不认真对待权力并滥用它时会发生什么。好吧，你在《权力悖论》一书中确实谈到了很多关于你在K.O. Drive长大后对相对无权无势的了解，你那里的许多邻居相对无权无势，他们对生活轨迹有一些可观察的影响。你能谈谈那个以及你从中学到了什么吗？
the last presidency as a textbook case example of somebody who caught us by surprise by, as Hannah Arendt says, like gaining your power by reaching a network and inspiring them. He spoke to people, and then the way that he conducted himself, and then the fallout of COVID, and our failure as a culture, speaks to what happens when we don't take power seriously and we abuse it. Well, you do talk quite a bit in your book The Power Paradox about what you learned regarding relative powerlessness as a result of growing up on K.O. Drive, and a lot of your neighbors there were relatively powerless and they had some observable effects on their life trajectories. Can you talk about that and really what you learned from that?
谢谢。谢谢你的提问，你知道。是的，金，我当时，这真的很有趣。我妈妈是州立大学的教授，也是女权主义者。她和我爸爸，我们从一个非常强大的中产阶级社区搬走，那里的学校很好，孩子们成为了心理学家、教师和医生等等。由于各种原因，我们搬到了加利福尼亚州内华达山脉贫穷的农村山麓。我们镇上有300人。我们住在大街上。街上有19个孩子。我想只有三个上了大学。两个是我哥哥和我，第三个是我的朋友梅莫，他上了大学是因为我父母真的鼓励他。所以那里非常贫穷，是农村贫困。当我写最后一章时
Thank you. Thanks for asking that, you know. Yeah, Kim, I was, it was really interesting. My mom was a professor at a state university and a feminist. And she and my dad, we went from a very strong middle-class community where the schools were good and the kids became psychologists and teachers and medical doctors and the like. And we moved for various reasons to the poor rural foothills of the Sierra's in California. And our town had 300 people. And we lived on a street. There were 19 kids on the street. I think only three went to college. Two were my brother and me and then a third was my friend Memo who went to college because of my parents who really encourage him to. So it was very poor and rural poor. And as I was writing the last chapter of the
权力悖论，我认为当我们思考权力时，很容易只想到权力的滥用。但你真的必须思考这个权力的集体过程。那些在社会中没有机会获得权力和影响力的人会发生什么，对吧，被剥夺权利的人，穷人。我是在他们周围长大的。我真的被像基利·马斯卡特尔、伊迪丝·陈和格雷格·米勒、雪莉·泰勒等人的工作所震撼，哇，如果你不被社会包容，没有发言权会发生什么？我们开始，人们开始了解，高皮质醇、压力、大脑的排斥区域、身体炎症、预期寿命缩短。南希·阿德勒1996年的开创性论文，你在社会地位的10级阶梯上跌落得越低，你活得就越短，对吧？我开始，金，在完成《权力悖论》时思考我一起长大的K.O. Drive周围的人。他们符合那个特征，对吧？他们是伟大的人类。他们会和你分享任何东西。你的餐桌上总有他们的位置。在某种意义上，它是田园诗般的，对吧，而且自由。但与此同时，人们死得更早。你知道，他们，你可以看着他们，有更多的抑郁。
power paradox, I think when we think about power, it's tempting to only think about the abuse of power. But you really have to think about this collective process of power. What happens to the people who are not given a chance at having power and influence in society, right, the disenfranchised, the poor. And I was growing up around them. And I was really struck by the work of people like Keeley Muscatel, Edith Chen and Greg Miller, Shelley Taylor, and others on, wow, what happens if you're not included in society and you don't have a voice? And we started, people started to learn, high cortisol, stress, rejection regions of your brain, inflammation in your body, shortened life expectancy. Nancy Adler's groundbreaking paper from 1996, the lower you fall on a rung, a 10-rung ladder of
有更多的临床水平的焦虑，我们知道这与较低的资源共同变化。当我想到我周围的人时，有人在40岁时就去世了。有人在60岁、55岁时去世。所以我心想，哇，当我10岁时，我从这个中产阶级世界搬到了一个贫穷的农村街道。它对我来说感觉很神奇，但它有这个……
status in society, the shorter you live, right? And I started, Kim, to think as I was finishing the power paradox about the people I grew up around on K.O. Drive. And they fit that profile, right? They were great human beings. They would share anything with you. You always had a spot at their dinner table. In some sense, it was idyllic, right, and free. But at the same time, people were dying younger. You know, they, and you could look at them, and there was more depression.
有一个缺点。这种悲伤。是的，那关乎权力。以及当社会不给人们机会时会发生什么？好吧，那么在硬币的另一面，是拥有权力的人，相对而言，不一定是绝对权力，但拥有权力的人，他们更健康吗？是的，你知道，这是，我的意思是，我们都，你知道，权力有滥用，权力有代价。我们喜欢谈论高处不胜寒，关于这个想法有有趣的变体。
There was more clinical levels of anxiety, which we know to co-vary with lower resources. and as I thought about the people around me, there were people dying when they were 40. There were people dying in 60, 55. And so I thought, wow, when I was 10 years old, I moved from this middle-class world and I moved to a poor rural country street lane. And it felt magical to me, but it had this...
但事实是，如果你有资源，你有权力和发言权，你对生活的感觉会更好。你对生活更快乐。你在工作中感受到更大的快乐。你在身体上更强壮。你有更长的预期寿命。你的孩子会活得更长，对吧？它是，这对我来说真的很有趣，
Had a downside. This sadness to it. Yeah, that was about power. and what happens when society doesn't give people a chance? Well, on the other side of the coin, then, are people who have power, relatively speaking, doesn't have to be absolute power, but people who have power, are they healthier? Yeah, you know, this is, I mean, we all, you know, there are abuses to power, there are costs to power. We like to talk about how it's lonely at the top, and there are interesting variations on that idea.
这是你之前的问题之一，那就是我们想要成为。想要我们周围的每个人都享受那种影响力感，对吧，和权力，因为这些后果或相关性。对于那些怀疑权力想要消除它的人，他们真的应该考虑这种如果你在你的环境中感到被授权，身心更强壮的特征。在你的工作中，你谈到权力是如何被给予的。是的。但我们每天都看到人们通过武力获得权力的情况，
but the raw facts of the matter are that if you have resources and you have power and voice, you feel better about life. You are happier about life. You feel greater joy in your work. You are physically more robust. You have a longer life expectancy. Your kids will live longer, right? It is, and that was really interesting to me,
无论是他们破坏同事，还是他们偷走某人的配偶，甚至推翻政府。所以你是说真正的权力永远不能被夺取或窃取吗？嗯，你知道，这是，这是一位社会学家的伟大观察，他说权力是给予你的。它不是被夺取的。这与马基雅维利关于所有权力都是被夺取的观点直接对立。我认为，而且我认为在许多方面，这种权力被给予的观察反映了你的影响力能力与其他人对你的领导力和你的权力、你的权力执行的看法之间的相互作用。在某种意义上，在许多环境中，它是给予你的。这就是持久权力的基础。
and it's one of your questions earlier, which is that we want to be. want everybody around us to enjoy that sense of influence, right, and power because of these consequences or correlates of it. And for people who are suspicious of power want to eliminate it, they should really be thinking about this profile of greater robustness in mind and body if you feel empowered in your context. In your work, you talk about how power is given. Yeah. But we see situations every day where people gain power by force,
是领导并以不滥用的方式使用权力。我们现在正在看安德鲁·科莫，他，你知道，就在今天。是的。你知道，16个月前，他是美国的英雄。对吧。现在他是一个耻辱，因为他，因为他，人们不再给他权力。那11名举报他的女性说，我们不能再给这个家伙权力了，他将失去他的权力。
whether they sabotage a coworker or they steal someone's spouse or even overthrow a government. So are you saying that true power can never be rested or stolen? Well, you know, this is the, this was a great observation of a sociologist who said power is given to you. It's not taken. And that's a direct confrontation with the Machiavellian view of all power is taken. And I think that the, and I think in many ways this observation of power is given reflects this interplay between your capacity to influence and what other people think about your leadership and your power, your execution of power. And in some sense, in a lot of context, it's given to you. And that's the basis of enduring power.
所以我认为在大多数关系中这是一个非常强大的动态，但随后你必须担心，这是，你知道，现在人们对威权主义思考很多。比如，白人至上主义或威权主义、政治威权主义可以在什么条件下兴起并使我们回到这些不对称的动态？我认为这是关键的警告信号之一，就是当你作为社区成员不再能给予
is to lead and use power in a way that does not abuse. We're looking right now at Andrew Cuomo, who was, you know, literally today. Yes. You know, 16 months ago, he was the hero of the United States. Right. And now he's a disgrace because of how, because he, people are no longer giving him power. Those 11 women reporting upon him are saying, we can't give this guy power anymore and he's going to lose his power.
人们权力时。坦率地说，特朗普试图贬低这一点。他试图破坏问责制，破坏对他行为的审查，破坏媒体，媒体的工作是给予人们权力并批评他们。这是权力何时健康以及何时失衡的警告信号。所以这真的取决于环境以及我们如何协商权力。真有趣你提到安德鲁·科莫，因为我正要问一个关于他的问题。
So I think it's a very powerful dynamic in most relationships, but then you have to worry, and this is, you know, right now people are thinking a lot about authoritarianism. Like, what are the conditions in which white supremacy or authoritarian, political authoritarianism can rise and return us to these asymmetric dynamics? And I think this is one of the key warning signs is when you no longer as a member of a community can give. people power. And Trump tried to degrade that, frankly. He tried to undermine accountability, undermine the scrutiny of his behavior, undermine the press, whose job is to be to give people power and to critique them. And that's a warning sign of when power is healthy and when it's imbalanced. So it really depends on the context and how we negotiate power. Funny that you should mention Andrew Cuomo, because I was going to ask a question about him.
当我是一名记者时，我报道过他的父亲，他是纽约州长。他的父亲是个恶霸。是的。我的意思是，他对记者是个恶霸。我相信他对其他人也是个恶霸。我只是想知道，比如，当我们长大时，谁教给我们这些权力风格？而且，我的意思是，你甚至可以将安德鲁·科莫与他的兄弟进行对比，他看起来，你知道，不是同一种人，但他们是在同一个父亲身边长大的。是的。
And when I was a journalist, I covered his father who was the governor in New York. And his father was a bully. Yes. I mean, he was a bully to journalists. I'm sure he was a bully to other people. And I'm just wondering, like, who teaches us these power styles as we grow up? And, I mean, you could even contrast, say, Andrew Cuomo with his brother, who seems like, you know, not the same kind of guy, but they grew up with the same dad. Yeah.
我的意思是，我们对你如何学习你的权力风格了解多少？我们不知道，这是一个极好的问题。事实上，莉安·坦布林基和我刚刚在《人格与社会心理学杂志》上发表了一篇关于你和我一直在谈论的这两种权力模式的论文，金，更协作的权力模式。例如，女性往往更倾向于支持这一点，而不是强制性的支配性权力模式。所以这些是这些在不同文化中以不同程度兴起的权力理论。
I mean, what do we know about how you learn your power style? We don't know, and that's a terrific question. And in fact, Leanne Tambrinkie and I just published a paper in the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology on kind of these two models of power that you and I have been talking about, Kim, more collaborative model of power. Women tend to endorse that a little bit more, for example, versus a coercive domineering model of power. And so these are these theories of power that rise to different degrees in different cultures. and historical moments and sectors of society, right? So we know my hunch is the coercive models more popular in Washington, D.C., in politics and so forth. But, you know, the, I think one of the really interesting findings in the science of power is,
和历史时刻以及社会部门，对吧？所以我们知道我的直觉是强制性模式在华盛顿特区、政治等领域更受欢迎。但是，你知道，我认为权力科学中真正有趣的发现之一是，
and there have been these large meta-analyses of our model, our thinking about power is changing. And you referred to this at the start of, as a conversation, culture, we're always changing our views of power. 40, 50 years ago is kind of the madman approach to power of like dominate men, you know, hierarchical. And we've moved in lots of ways to a more, a different theory or approach to power, more collaborative. I do a lot of work with medical doctors.
并且已经有了关于我们模式的大型荟萃分析，我们对权力的思考正在改变。你在谈话开始时提到了这一点，文化，我们总是在改变我们对权力的看法。40、50年前是那种疯狂的权力方法，比如支配男人，你知道，等级制度。我们已经在很多方面转向了一种更、不同的权力理论或方法，更协作。我与医生做了很多工作。
30 or 40 years ago, the medical doctor was more Machiavellian in executing power. And now it's much more collaborative. So it's always in flux. How do we get it from our families? We don't know. It's a great question. How do we get it as a function of culture? If I'm from a super touch-oriented culture, does that get me into more trouble? Like, you know, that may be the case. So that's a great question for future research. Well, let's shift gears for a minute and talk about gossip, because I know you've looked at that as well. What's the role of gossip relative to power and how has social media, affected gossip and by extension its connection to power. What a terrific question. Wow. Yeah, people always, when they hear I sing the brazes of gossip,
30或40年前，医生在执行权力时更马基雅维利。现在它更具协作性。所以它总是在变化。我们如何从家庭中获得它？我们不知道。这是一个很好的问题。我们如何作为文化的功能获得它？如果我来自一个超级注重接触的文化，这会让我陷入更多麻烦吗？比如，你知道，情况可能就是这样。所以这对未来的研究是一个很好的问题。好吧，让我们换个话题，谈谈八卦，因为我知道你也研究过那个。八卦相对于权力的作用是什么，社交媒体如何影响了八卦，进而影响了它与权力的联系。这是一个极好的问题。哇。是的，人们总是，当他们听到我赞美八卦时，
are like, I'm going to go after that guy. You know, so, you know, this came from a brilliant paper, our interest in gossip by Christopher Bum, who's an anthropologist. And it was a prize-winning paper, I think, from 1991, where he studied 4,800-Gyenne. other societies, right? And these are people living in groups
就像，我要去对付那个家伙。你知道，所以，你知道，这来自一篇精彩的论文，我们对克里斯托弗·布姆的八卦的兴趣，他是一位人类学家。我认为这是一篇获奖论文，来自1991年，他研究了4800个吉恩。其他社会，对吧？这些人生活在群体中
or different kinds of circumstances, but in the conditions in which we evolved, ethologists and anthropologists had made systematic observations about their power structures, right? So you drop into a group of people in the Amazon or in New Guinea or parts of Indonesia. And what are the power dynamics like? They're modern humans, but they don't have, you know,
或不同种类的环境中，但在我们进化的条件下，动物行为学家和人类学家对他们的权力结构进行了系统的观察，对吧？所以你进入亚马逊、新几内亚或印度尼西亚部分地区的一群人中。权力动态是什么样的？他们是现代人类，但他们没有，你知道，
the Wall Street and capitalism and so forth. And he made this really interesting observation. It was more egalitarian, which is interesting, right? Power is more equally distributed prior to the advent of agriculture and big religion. And he talked about this really interesting dynamic by which the group gives power to the different individuals and levels it, reduces it, keeps them in check. And it's things like teasing, which I've studied, commentary, gossip. And if you really violate the rules of that group, you're exiled, right?
华尔街和资本主义等等。他做出了这个非常有趣的观察。它更平等，这很有趣，对吧？在农业和大型宗教出现之前，权力分配得更均匀。他谈到了这种非常有趣的动态，群体通过这种动态将权力给予不同的个人并使其平坦化、减少它、控制他们。它是像戏弄这样的事情，我研究过，评论，八卦。如果你真的违反了那个群体的规则，你就会被流放，对吧？
And you're just like, no, you're no longer part of this group. But he said gossip's really important that people and also forms of humility. And so in those societies around the world, a deep universal is to gossip about people when they violate the social contract and they start to abuse their power. They take too much of a resource or too much of some food or they, like you said earlier, they flirt too inappropriately with somebody's sexual partner, et cetera. And so that gave us this idea that gossip is a way in which we constrain the abuse of power. Right.
你就像，不，你不再是这个群体的一部分了。但他说八卦非常重要，人们还有谦逊的形式。所以在那里的世界各地的社会中，一个深刻的普遍现象是当人们违反社会契约并开始滥用权力时，八卦他们。他们拿走了太多的资源或太多的食物，或者他们，像你之前说的，他们与某人的性伴侣调情太不恰当，等等。所以这给了我们这个想法，即八卦是我们限制权力滥用的一种方式。对。
And lo and behold, our research is found in social groups. People gossip about the Machiavellian in their group. They're like, did you see him? You know, he's totally offending these. other people are coercing these other people. One of my favorite examples is newspapers. You know, we look at newspapers, which are predecessor to social media, they emerged in the 18th century largely to gossip about well-to-do people, right? Like, oh, he's having sex with the maid, etc. So gossip has this really important function when it's used, right? And, you know,
果不其然，我们的研究发现在社会群体中。人们八卦群体中的马基雅维利主义者。他们就像，你看到他了吗？你知道，他完全冒犯了这些。其他人正在胁迫这些其他人。我最喜欢的例子之一是报纸。你知道，我们看报纸，它是社交媒体的前身，它们在18世纪出现，主要是为了八卦富裕的人，对吧？比如，哦，他正在和女仆发生性关系，等等。所以八卦在被正确使用时有这个非常重要的功能，而且，你知道，
it's so, Kim, your question is so original because it's striking. Like a lot of social media is kind of a form of commentary. And like, you know, Yelp is a way in which you kind of gossip about a restaurant, you know, with other people. Even the chat function in Zoom, when I teach now, student, I see the chat comments and they're like, oh my God, Professor Keltner, do you see his nose hairs? They're ridiculous. Or he's got to brush his teeth or he said this before, you know. I'm like, wow, I better be on my game here. But it can obviously get out of hand.
它是如此，金，你的问题如此原创，因为它很引人注目。比如很多社交媒体是一种评论形式。而且比如，你知道，Yelp是你与其他人八卦餐厅的一种方式，你知道。即使是Zoom中的聊天功能，当我教书时，学生，我看到聊天评论，他们就像，天哪，凯尔特纳教授，你看到他的鼻毛了吗？它们太荒谬了。或者他得刷牙，或者他之前说过这个，你知道。我心想，哇，我最好在这里保持状态。但它显然会失控。
And gossip has to be constrained. And so it has its place. Like every human behavior, it can be excessive and problematic. And I think at its core, it emerged to keep us, keep the abuses of power in check. I think it's also given people who wouldn't have had power otherwise a whole lot of new power. I mean, just it's astonishing how somebody who has 25,000 followers on Twitter can really, you know, change can move markets. Oh my God, you know, and like the new Twitter politics and Twitter power is striking, you know, and it does. It's this interesting democratization of power where now
八卦必须受到限制。所以它有它的位置。像每一种人类行为一样，它可能是过度的和有问题的。我认为在它的核心，它出现是为了控制权力的滥用。我认为它也给了那些本来没有权力的人很多新的权力。我的意思是，仅仅是，令人惊讶的是，一个在Twitter上有25000名粉丝的人真的可以，你知道，改变，可以移动市场。天哪，你知道，像新的Twitter政治和Twitter权力是惊人的，你知道，而且它确实。这是权力的这种有趣的民主化，现在
if you can get an audience, you can have power, right? And just to, you know, wrap up, you know, for the skeptics out there, Matt Feinberg, who's up at Toronto and Rob Willer have done really nice research. And I was part of one of the studies and they have other work showing like, Like, in group settings, if you just let them know, like, hey, man, you guys get a chance to gossip about each other, people behave pretty well. They're more cooperative. And that tells us that there's this cooperative social function of gossip that we shouldn't forget about. So something else in the news recently, we witnessed two multi-billionaires who got shot into space because they had the money to do it. Now, was that just a show of power?
如果你能获得观众，你就能拥有权力，对吧？而且只是为了，你知道，总结一下，你知道，对于那些怀疑论者，多伦多大学的马特·费恩伯格和罗伯·威勒做了非常好的研究。我是其中一项研究的一部分，他们有其他工作表明，比如，在群体环境中，如果你只是让他们知道，比如，嘿，伙计，你们有机会互相八卦，人们表现得相当好。他们更合作。这告诉我们，八卦有这种合作的社会功能，我们不应该忘记。所以最近新闻里的其他事情，我们目睹了两位亿万富翁被射入太空，因为他们有钱这样做。现在，那只是权力的展示吗？
And could you tell me what was it about Jeff Bezos's cowboy hat? What was that supposed to mean? Because I think it really backfired on him. It's so absurd when you think about, and this, this, I feel like in writing the power paradox and doing this work, you would hope that like people with all these resources, you know, there are studies that show that the richest person, in each country around the world, if they gave away half their wealth
你能告诉我杰夫·贝佐斯的牛仔帽是怎么回事吗？那意味着什么？因为我认为它真的对他适得其反。当你想到时，这太荒谬了，而且这个，我觉得在写《权力悖论》和做这项工作时，你会希望像拥有所有这些资源的人，你知道，有研究表明，世界各国最富有的人，如果他们捐出一半的财富
could probably solve the problem of poverty in that country, that's mind-blowing to me, right? If poverty is the central social problem alongside, you know, white supremacy of our culture, wow, just a little bit of generosity of these Jeff Bezos's and Elon Musk, and it really changed things, and they don't, you know.
可能就能解决那个国家的贫困问题，这对我来说太令人震惊了，对吧？如果贫困是核心社会问题，伴随着，你知道，我们文化的白人至上主义，哇，杰夫·贝佐斯和埃隆·马斯克只要有一点慷慨，它真的改变了事情，而他们没有，你知道。
And it's just funny to me, you know, there's this, there's this, pronounced tendency for people with a lot of power, they want attention, they want to be looked up to, you know, it's not random. Then when we shifted to big God religions 12,000 years ago, 15,000 years ago, we went from like an indigenous society's communal rooms where everybody was on the same par, right? And we started to build pyramids and obelisks where the person in power is looked up to because you look up and you go, wow, he's almost a god, you know. And so it cracks me up when I saw this, you know, like Jeff Beezot's being
这对我来说很有趣，你知道，有这个，有这个，明显的倾向，拥有大量权力的人，他们想要关注，他们想要被仰望，你知道，这不是随机的。然后当我们在12000年前，15000年前转向大型上帝宗教时，我们从像土著社会的公共房间，每个人都在同一水平，对吧？我们开始建造金字塔和方尖碑，在那里掌权的人被仰望，因为你抬头看，你会说，哇，他几乎是神，你知道。所以当我看到这个时，我笑死了，你知道，比如杰夫·贝佐斯被
shot into space. It's like, of course. He didn't get a little sub and go underneath the ocean, you know, which is probably harder to do. He shot himself into space because he likes to be high above people. That's a deep universal. And he wanted attention. And boy, the powerful will go to no ends to be above people and to get a lot of attention. What a what a lampoonable waste of resources and opportunity. But just on a more quotidian level, I mean, if an average person thinks that he or she wants power, what's the best way to get more of it? It's interesting. There's there's work that shows like Cameron Anderson, my collaborator at Berkeley, has this nice finding. You know, you can study these groups. No one has a position of power. They just start doing something together.
射入太空。这就像，当然。他没有弄个小潜水艇潜入海底，你知道，这可能更难做到。他把自己射入太空，因为他喜欢高高在上。这是一个深刻的普遍现象。他想要关注。天哪，掌权者会不惜一切代价高高在上并获得大量关注。多么令人嘲讽的资源和机会的浪费。但只是在更日常的层面上，我的意思是，如果一个普通人认为他或她想要权力，获得更多权力的最好方法是什么？这很有趣。有，有研究表明，比如卡梅伦·安德森，我在伯克利的合作者，有这个很好的发现。你知道，你可以研究这些群体。没有人拥有权力职位。他们只是开始一起做某事。
And they can figure out who rises. And there are things like speak up. And so one of the things I tell people as they adapt to leadership is like, make sure you voice yourself, right? Even if you're introverted, even if maybe you come from working in a gender biased context, like take the courage to speak up, connect to other people, ask great questions. propose bold ideas and be ready to back off them. And one of the, I think, motivations for me to write the power paradox and to do this work is it shows that, and also to remember how much of power and influence in the world is local and comes from unexpected people, right? The best-selling writer of all time is Agatha Christie, you know, no comparison.
他们可以弄清楚谁会崛起。有像大声说出来这样的事情。所以我告诉人们适应领导力时的一件事是，确保你表达自己，对吧？即使你内向，即使也许你来自性别偏见的环境，比如拿出勇气大声说出来，与他人联系，提出伟大的问题。提出大胆的想法并准备好退缩。我认为我写《权力悖论》并做这项工作的一个动机是它表明，也要记住世界上多少权力和影响力是局部的，来自意想不到的人，对吧？有史以来最畅销的作家是阿加莎·克里斯蒂，你知道，无法比较。
I believe the most important technological innovation alongside the computer of the 20th century was the birth control pill. And that was led by Margaret Sanger, who's this kind of an unconventional person with no resources. You could go on it, Black Lives Matter, abolitionism, et cetera, were led by people who influenced locally through social networks, through courage. And so I think when we rethink power, and it's not just wealth or domination, or being a male, but it has this local quality to it. It gives us reason to go after it and for social good. So is being benevolent and cooperative than the best way to hang on to power once you get it?
我相信20世纪与计算机并列的最重要的技术创新是避孕药。这是由玛格丽特·桑格领导的，她是一个没有资源的非传统人物。你可以继续，黑人的命也是命，废奴主义等等，都是由通过社交网络、通过勇气在局部施加影响的人领导的。所以我认为当我们重新思考权力时，它不仅仅是财富或支配，或成为男性，但它具有这种局部性。它给了我们追求它并为了社会利益的理由。那么仁慈和合作是获得权力后保持权力的最好方法吗？
Yeah, you know, people always press me on that. And I think there's a lot of neat new work by people like Rob Willer and economists, that, you know, sharing resources in a thoughtful way is a really good way to rise in social status, right? Building social ties is a good way to gain power. There's amazing social network research showing that if you can build a lot of strong ties with people where they like you and trust you in finance firms
是的，你知道，人们总是就此向我施压。我认为像罗伯·威勒和经济学家这样的人有很多很棒的新工作，即，以深思熟虑的方式分享资源是提升社会地位的好方法，对吧？建立社会联系是获得权力的好方法。有惊人的社交网络研究表明，如果你能与人们建立许多强大的联系，让他们喜欢你并信任你，在金融公司
or tech firms, you'll have a lot of power because you're kind of in the mix and you're getting a lot of information. So that's all pro-social. But I also think, you know, you have to be ready to fight for stuff. You know, you have to be ready to call out the Machiavellian and to stand up for stuff and draw a hard line. So I'd say 75% in many of today's contexts that our audience might be working in is about connecting, empathizing, sharing. But be ready to fight for the things you believe in. Do the dynamics of power change within people as they age?
或科技公司，你将拥有很多权力，因为你处于混合状态，并且你获得了大量信息。所以这一切都是亲社会的。但我也认为，你知道，你必须准备好为事情而战。你知道，你必须准备好指出马基雅维利主义者，并为事情挺身而出，划定底线。所以我说在当今许多听众可能工作的环境中，75%是关于联系、共情、分享。但要准备好为你相信的事情而战。权力的动态会随着人们年龄的增长而改变吗？
So maybe kids who, you know, were powerful or even bullies, will they continue to be that way as adults? What does the trajectory look like through life? That's a question that we regrettably, psychological, developmental longitudinal studies are hard to do. You've got to follow people for 10 years. And in some sense, we don't have an answer to that question. And one of the critiques of a lot of the literature I'm citing is, like a lot of social psychology is it's atemporal. It studies people in one instant in time.
所以也许小时候，你知道，有权力的，甚至是恶霸，他们成年后会继续那样吗？生命轨迹看起来是什么样的？这是一个我们遗憾地，心理学、发展纵向研究很难做的问题。你必须跟踪人们10年。在某种意义上，我们没有那个问题的答案。我引用的许多文献的批评之一是，像很多社会心理学一样，它是无时间的。它在某一瞬间研究人们。
And Kim, your question speaks to one of the most interesting things about power, which is, how does it evolve over time? Right? If I'm, you know, I think we're in one of the most dynamic periods to ask that question. Like, a lot of women are rising in power. A lot of people of color are starting to rise. rise in power. Hopefully indigenous people will be rising in power to in education and career and wealth and the like. And so what happens to their conceptions of power? And it's a wide open question. We we do know with respect to the Machiavellian bullies tend to be more Machiavellian
而且金，你的问题谈到了关于权力最有趣的事情之一，那就是，它如何随时间演变？对吧？如果我，你知道，我认为我们正处于询问那个问题的最动态的时期之一。比如，很多女性正在崛起。很多有色人种开始崛起。权力崛起。希望土著人民在教育、职业和财富等方面也会崛起。那么他们对权力的概念会发生什么？这是一个完全开放的问题。我们确实知道，关于马基雅维利主义者，恶霸往往更马基雅维利。
and bullying does have this interesting trajectory where it peaks when you're 11 and 12 years old. and starts to taper, but it is this stable, the Boolean 11 is going to be the Machiavellian in the workplace, right, who's really undermining people and causing discomfort. So there's a little bit of stability there to your question, but again, a wide open, interesting question for us. What are the other big questions left to answer in power? I mean, I'm sure that this is probably an unfair question because there's so much we don't know. But if you had your druthers, I mean, what are you looking at now? What would you like us to know more about?
欺凌行为确实有一个有趣的轨迹，它在11到12岁时达到顶峰，然后开始减弱，但它是一种稳定的特质。那个11岁的孩子长大后可能会成为职场中的马基雅维利主义者，对吧？他们会暗中破坏他人，造成不安。所以，正如你所问的，这里确实存在一定的稳定性，但这对于我们来说仍然是一个广阔而有趣的问题。在权力研究中，还有哪些重大的未解之谜？我知道这可能是一个不公平的问题，因为我们还有太多未知。但如果让你选择，你现在关注的是什么？你希望我们更多地了解什么？
One question is the, and you've already gotten to a part of it, is the trajectory question or the dynamics over time. Regrettably in the United States, we have a lot of stability and immobility in our economic class where we tend, it's changed, where we aren't as mobiles we used to think we were. But there are people who rise in power. And so there's this interesting question. of like, do I abuse power if I rise from a lower class background and now, you know, I'm Bill Clinton versus I'm born into privilege and I have power, right? So there's this interesting, does that change things that we don't know, rising to power versus it coming to you because of your context of birth? So that's an interesting question. One of the really interesting questions to me, is this how we approach power, right? Do we really hew to this authoritarian Machiavellian view? Or do we endorse this more collaborative, cooperative view?
一个问题是——你已经触及了其中的一部分——关于轨迹的问题，或者说是随时间变化的动态。遗憾的是，在美国，我们的经济阶层存在很大的稳定性和固化，我们并没有像过去认为的那样具有流动性。但确实有人能够获得权力。所以这里有一个有趣的问题：如果我出身于底层，通过努力获得了权力，比如比尔·克林顿，与我生来就享有特权并拥有权力相比，我在滥用权力方面会有所不同吗？所以，这种通过努力获得权力与因出身背景而获得权力，是否会改变某些事情，这是我们尚不清楚的。这是一个有趣的问题。对我来说，另一个非常有趣的问题是我们如何看待权力。我们是真的坚持这种威权主义的马基雅维利式观点，还是支持这种更具协作性和合作性的观点？
And you've kind of brought this up. And to me, it's interesting to think about what context do we cultivate this, right? Are there cultural differences? You know, psychology probably and, you know, social welfare and so forth is probably more collaborative in its approach to power. You move over to finance, and there's going to be a little bit more coercive approach to power. So where did the theories of power originate? You asked me that question earlier, and that's an interesting cultural question, right?
你刚才也提到了这一点。对我来说，思考我们在什么样的背景下培养这种观念是很有趣的。是否存在文化差异？你知道，心理学、社会福利等领域在权力处理上可能更倾向于协作。而如果你转向金融领域，可能会有更多强制性的权力运用。那么，权力理论起源于何处？你之前问过我这个问题，这是一个有趣的文化问题，对吧？
So I would point to those two questions as needing answers soon. Well, this has been really interesting. I very much appreciate you taking the time to talk to us. Thank you, Dr. Keltner. Thank you for your wonderful questions, Kim, and for provoking thoughts about what we need to do next. So thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.combeatingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. And please leave us a review.
所以我认为这两个问题需要尽快得到解答。好的，这次谈话非常有趣。非常感谢你抽出时间与我们交流。谢谢你，凯尔特纳博士。也谢谢你提出的精彩问题，金，并引发了关于我们下一步该做什么的思考。谢谢。你可以在 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 以及你获取播客的任何平台收听《心理学谈话》的往期节目。请给我们留下评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. At speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。地址是 speakingofpsychology，连在一起，后面接 @apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康丁。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。